we're here at the ftth council event in
Munich what I'm talking to Olaf toca
only have you given a presentation today
to do a lot with financing and
cooperation tell me more about the
highlights of that my presentation was
about the product I be broadband that we
build em Lizzie Georgetown to be able to
finance all these fiber projects in
Georgetown and we bundled together all
the projects as one and we call it one
big crozier project called broadband
Jersey Hodge time this was why we were
able to to finance this together with
you european investment bank and i think
the success walks through the
cooperation without this cooperation
with eib on the out on the one hand but
also with the Ministry of Economic
sinfully fortune and all the other
person's into the ocean that nothing
would happen and so in the future what
needs to be done to make sure you know
continuing finances available and the
ftth deployment can carry on very
successfully okay a big problem that we
today have to cope with is that we don't
find other credit institutions to
finance together with us because we we
are the federal investment bank we are
belonging to the state and so we are not
able to finance one hundred percent but
only fifty percent of the projects and
we need to find other credit
institutions who financed the other
fifty percent and this is very difficult
for today but are you confident we can
do it yes I'm sure I'm a believer oh
that's great and thanks for speaking
with us thank you very much
ftth connects the world when are you
getting connected ladies and gentlemen
welcome to Munich for the ninth edition
of the ftth conference creating a
brighter future